From ChatGPT to Dall-E,
It might seem like the pace of progress
in artificial intelligence is unstoppable.
But the artificial neural networks
that underpin these programs are coming up
against some major limitations.
For one, they have a hard time reasoning.
Human brains
are able to reason by analogy.
When we see something new,
we don't have to grow new neurons.
We can generalize new concepts
from existing knowledge,
But artificial neural networks
struggle to reason by analogy.
In this way,
When confronting new information,
they often require more artificial nodes
to scale up their statistical abilities,
which enables them to learn new concepts.
This approach is called statistical AI.
Statistically, AI is at the heart
of deep neural networks,
but there is another competing approach
known as symbolic AI,
which uses logic-based programing
and makes use of symbols
to represent concepts and rules.
So by their very nature
they are incompatible.
And the big challenge
is that how we can combine them together
to get the best of both worlds.
An emerging approach called hyperdimensional computing
aims to do just that.
It taps into the power of statistical AI,
while also trying to emulate
symbolic computing.
It does this by using vectors,
ordered lists of numbers
that can also represent arrows in space.
Depending on where they're pointing,
these vectors can represent information in
a highly complex, multi-dimensional way.
They can embody nuances and traits
or concepts just by small changes
to their orientation.
These vectors can combine to represent
new concepts, then be pulled apart again
to discern how they were formed.
And crucially,
these hyperdimensional vectors
can encode information
without having to add more nodes
to the network.
The moment that we bring
hyperdimensional computing or better
symbolic architectures
and marry it with the statistical methods
such as deep neural network,
we can have a certain advantages.
In March 2023, computer scientists
at IBM Research in Zurich
made a dramatic breakthrough by combining
statistical and symbolic methods
to solve the Ravens progressive matrix,
a puzzle that asks an
AI to predict an image to fill
the final square of a three by three grid.
This is a classical problem.
The first aspects is the perception part,
where we look at different visual objects
and then we have to recognize
certain aspects of the objects.
For example,
what is the shape of the object?
What is the color, what is the size?
All this kind of the property.
And the second aspect is to perform
some abstract reasoning on top of these
kind of attributes of the objects
to be able to solve a puzzle.
So for the first time,
we combine hyperdimensional computing
or better symbolic architectures
machinery, with deep neural networks
to be able to solve abstract
reasoning problems at a scale.
Essentially, we can build inside the neural network
a machinery that is able to emulate
any symbolic computing task
that is hard for the neural network itself
to do.
The researchers also broke new ground
by solving the problem in record speed.
We were able to significantly accelerate
the inference times of some of abstract
reasoning tasks
by 250 times, having a method
that is able to search
in this kind of the space rapidly,
it's quite crucial to be able
to make them quite practical for
for larger scale and real world problems.
Although more work is needed, researchers
like Rahimi
hope that hyperdimensional computing
could be faster, more transparent,
and more energy efficient than current
AI platforms.
We can substantially reduce energy consumption.
We are talking about, you know, ten
times, 100 times lower energy consumptions
which can directly transfer to
lowering the carbon footprint
once we are performing
the inference of this kind of the models.
Solving driving progressive
mattresses was just a prototype.
It was, so far amazing,
but the fun is just beginning,
that's the beauty.
In the 1990s, mathematician Peter
Shor developed an algorithm
that threatened to break the Internet.
He was trying to understand
the power of quantum computers
and realized
that they would be able to rapidly break
large numbers into their prime factors.
That would undermine
one of the central methods of modern
cryptography that has safeguarded
online privacy for decades.
So when I discovered the algorithm,
I just called it the factoring algorithm,
the quantum factoring algorithm,
and I published it.
And soon people started calling
it Shor's algorithm.
At the heart of Shor's algorithm
is the act of repeatedly multiplying
one number with itself
until the output of a certain function
starts repeating. The required number
of multiplications called the functions
period can be used to find
the prime factors of any large number.
For the last 30 years,
this has been the fastest known algorithm
for factoring integers.
Then in August 2023, mathematician Oded
Regev published
a groundbreaking new paper.
Shor's algorithm is is great in the sense
that it allows
quantum computers to factor integers
and do it quickly.
I was asking myself
if it can be made even faster.
Regev suspected that he could speed up
Shor's algorithm
by transforming the periodic function
from one dimension to multiple dimensions.
That meant including more numbers,
multiplying each with itself
many times over to find the period
of repetition in the outputs.
In doing so,
Regev established an improved method
to factor integers
faster and more efficiently.
Shor's algorithm is about finding
how long you have to walk on the line
to get back to where you started.
In the new algorithm,
we no longer walk on the line.
We walk on the plane
or even three dimensional space or more.
the idea is that you can walk
both in, right, left,
but also top down of the plane.
So it could be, for instance,
that if you walk four steps to the right
and five step up,
you'll be back to where you started from.
Oded's improvement
to my algorithm came out of the blue.
There wasn't any,
you know, work leading up to it.
It just had a really good idea.
And he sat down, figured it out
and published a paper.
Like Shor's algorithm.
Regev's new algorithm
remains theoretical in nature.
Speaking to a potential future
when quantum computing becomes
more practical.
I would be happy if if turns out that this new algorithm
is more practical,
it has some of the components
that could make it more practical.
But it's not clear yet
if it's really there.
My algorithm is what, 30 years old now?
And Oded found an improvement on it
that nobody had thought of before.
I wouldn't be surprised
if people came up with more innovative
quantum algorithms. And its quite possible
that someone will improve
factoring algorithm even further.
We already knew how to factor integers
using Shor's algorithm.
So this new algorithm is kind of
just a speedup.
What I would really like to know
is if quantum computers can do things
that we just didn't know how to do.
Which movie do these emojis represent?
When researchers asked three
different large language models,
they got very different answers.
The simplest
AI struggled to come up
with a coherent answer.
A somewhat more complex model, spit out
something reasonable but still wrong.
But the most complex system nailed it in
just one try.
This impressive result can be explained
by a range of exciting new abilities.
AI researchers are calling
emergent behaviors.
Something that is not present
in a small language model
that becomes present in a larger
model can be said to have emerged.
We don't think that it will be there
and then we scale it up
and all of a sudden
this phenomenon is already there.
So it's not necessarily
a predictable phenomenon.
Emergence happens
when a system behaves in ways
its individual units don't on their own.
This phenomenon can be seen across nature,
such as when lifeless atoms
give rise to living cells, water molecules
create waves and starlings
swarm and swoop as one.
Researchers are seeing that if enough
digital nodes combine in large
language models, surprising
new behaviors can emerge.
These behaviors are a distinct departure
from older neural networks
which process language word by painstaking word.
In 2017, a key piece of code
known as a transformer was introduced
to LLMs, enabling neural networks
to analyze words in parallel.
Now, LLMs can process
strings of text in an instant.
The models we were training before
seemed to struggle with a lot of, kind of
more abstract tasks, more generalization.
And what we've seen since transformers
is that if we train much larger models,
they're better at those tasks.
The magic of transformers
is that they're extremely good
at solving sequence prediction problems.
So given a bunch of items in a sequence,
predict the next thing.
And this is particularly good for building
generative models
of, for example, language and also images.
This year, researchers
have reported a range
of emergent behaviors
that enable LLMs to solve problems
they've never seen before.
This is known as zero shot
or few shot learning and it's long
been a goal in artificial intelligence.
But as exciting as the results are,
researchers still have questions
about what exactly is underpinning
these emergent abilities.
People are trying to figure out
at what point is there a tipping point.
One theory suggests that emergence happens
when large language models
break down
complex tasks into smaller steps.
This process is called
chain of thought reasoning.
But the true source of the tipping point
into emergence remains a mystery.
The models get better as they get bigger
and people are releasing
bigger models at a pretty rapid clip.
Meanwhile, the science of understanding
what's happening under the hood progresses
more slowly than that.
So one of the challenges with emergence
is that it's unpredictable.
Because on the one hand, you know, bigger
models typically mean better models.
But on the other hand,
bigger models also can demonstrate
novel behaviors that the developers
didn't anticipate a priori.
These can be beneficial behaviors,
but they can also be harmful behaviors.
So the ways in which they will be used
or are used are still unfolding.
And therefore it's equally important
to measure
the possible types of harms
that might be espoused in these models
and how they emerge
or do not emerge with scale.
And so things feel quite unpredictable
right now.
But I don't think they
will always be unpredictable.